[Music]
in no common sense news Gee's submitted
by jocelyn from jersey hello
a United flight attendant is blamed for
the death of a dog after loading it into
the overhead bin has been [ __ ] off
left and right and up and down [ __ ]
let's not burn this woman down can we
agree what should we do pour water on it
you put a dog in an overhead bin
you should hear about the other dog wait
there's more there's this other dog well
I mean that's not the story but this
other these dogs got switched and one of
them went to Japan instead of Kansas oh
but did they die no that's on the state
first and then the Japan thing happened
yeah does this dog with a suitcase did
you expect why are they putting him in
the overhead bin he was barking yeah he
was a lot you gotta give that doggy some
sleepy sleepy medicines yeah yeah well
okay so that's why I don't fly with my
dogs dogs aren't meant to fly neither
humans actually just don't fly your pets
in United just don't do that because I
don't even wanna I'm a human being and I
don't even want to fly United I don't
trust that mother they [ __ ] lost my
luggage like twice and one time it was
international to [ __ ] [ __ ] the
US Department of Transportation said
that there have been twenty enough money
there have been 24 animals that died in
major airlines care last year 18 of
those animals were in the care of United
Delta and American Airlines each
reported two animal deaths so 18 out of
24 animals have died I also don't think
that we should crucify the airlines
because a lot of these people bring in
the dogs on the plane they're kind of
they found a loophole with the emotional
support thing if you actually have a
written prescription from a psychologist
I think you're cool but if you go to one
of those websites like I did service
animal and you get a fake service animal
car like we did dude and you're bringing
your dog on the plane I'm trained dog
that [ __ ] is like I need a service
animal because I have I have depression
right yeah like if you did [ __ ] like
that the way we did it it's kind it's
kind of your fault for bringing
untrained dogs but if you really need an
animal and you got your dog from one of
those breeders that's meant to be
trained trained or whatever that dog
wouldn't be barking up a storm but some
people just travel with their dogs to
like yeah you pay yeah but those dogs
and I cannot put in yet the right area
not and the overhead bin though well
that's where the flight attendant [ __ ]
up obviously because she's saying that
she didn't hear them tell her that there
was a dog inside of that carrier
she claims a student here but if it was
barking about it come on there's
witnesses around that they they are
testifying like yes they told her many
times there's a dog in here there's a
dog in here and she's still like would
not let them keep the dog does she speak
English they have to I don't know this
flight was from Houston to New York so
they speak Houston English which is
really different she's [ __ ] crazy I
do that it always ends with the yeah
well I mean should we blame the flight
attendant though because if the dog is
barking a [ __ ] ton and then she's just
trying to keep the peace and do her job
trying to keep the peace Thank You Man
thank you she's trying to keep the peace
no so the dog was not barking when okay
so the dog was barking mid-flight so
like as soon as like the flight took off
like he started barking so doll time did
you have parking for the [ __ ]
overhead bin oh I thought it was just
shut up baggy
no the dog was fine under the seat like
it was just not causing any problem they
were following the rules they kept him
in the kennel abhi I bet you it was like
the the thing was poking out two inches
oh my god I hate that you know you gotta
you gotta put that up sir knees we alway
in the Cedars that [ __ ] there it's a
it's a hazard for if we have emergency
landing and I'm like we're dead if we
have an emergency landing you're dead
I'm dead you're dead your kid's gonna
get a phone call and it's gonna be a sad
one you know it's funny I'm so I'm so
[ __ ] like randomly defined I don't
know why I do this but they're like
before we take off make sure you ever
see Pope I'm like really I tuck it right
under my hoodie exactly good for ya I'll
do it and like put your phone in
airplane mode really like shut it on
like show me a statistic we're asleep on
an airplane save one life yeah show me
you probably can't actually
please don't tell me thank you I think a
flight thank you for that airplane mode
my bed thank you for that statistic
yeah well the flight attendant was like
that was her whole thing was the fact
that it was she was saying I was gonna
block the aisle even though I was like
under the front of their seat dogs don't
block [ __ ] yeah so it was a little puppy
a ten month old puppy Oh french bulldog
named cookie those things are expensive
cookies though like Oh pizza
Oh cookie dough cookie dough Oh like
small little pieces of like coke did you
store those dollars means that puppy got
suffocated and overhead many things were
airtight in their [ __ ] yeah oh and also
like they were saying like when the
flights in it put the dog up in the
thing she just treated it like it was
just a bag well the dog was barking why
didn't the owner stand up and [ __ ]
take your dog I would have done that in
two five two seconds if I was if I even
witness is happening I would get the dog
I heard the dog I'm [ __ ] opening down
multiple address that so it was a mom
traveling with like a baby because she
was holding the baby with her 11 year
old daughter Sophia this little dog was
Sophia's birthday present oh it wasn't
one mainly responsible for the dog but
anyway they're saying Sophia was saying
that she did want to attend the dog when
it was back wanted to but I got scared
no but there was too much turbulence and
they couldn't couldn't ever check up on
what in the almost four hour flight
those four hours of turbulent stuff come
on man even terms like to get up I'm
such a badass how I got up cuz I'm such
a badass of course I would have torn my
seatbelt off cuz out of the buckle thing
you know what I would have gotten that
dog down from the thing and you know
what bring the whole plane now and then
if you're gonna put it up an overhead
bed i if she had to take a [ __ ]
turbulence would not stop her from going
to the bathroom she's 11 years old let's
no no no the mom the mom she's holding
in the 11 you're all could hold the baby
that's it after the baby I would say
this till if the dog was a puppy
not a very good idea to have a puppy on
a [ __ ] four-hour flight you don't
know their situation you don't know the
story you don't know what the
circumstances are David to have a puppy
on a four-hour flight that dog can't
hold its bowels well they could have
been moving I mean who knows what their
story is yeah well you shouldn't have
gotten a dog if you knew nothing
shouldn't even had a dog this should
have [ __ ] kids the point is it's like
if you have a puppy you guys know like
puppies have to take the [ __ ] piss
every like hour you know or [ __ ] but
they do [ __ ] puppies all the time
especially if they like got like a
purebred French boy they might have went
to the breeder or whatever that's the
only way to bring back this photo was
tweeted out by a woman who said like
that's how everyone found out about the
story this woman tweeted out something
along the lines of like my heart is
broken like and then explained the
situation or what happened with them and
the dog and this was after yeah this is
once they landed so she they were just
like bawling so wait they opened it and
in there like the next one I'm about to
show you is cookie Oh No why would they
show us a dead dog it was found inside
of his carriers well he's not a puppy
that's nine month yeah there's still
juvenile this is what he was like oh
he's a cutie oh man that's so sad dude
it's just so ridiculous the reason the
mom didn't get up could be sheep I just
thought she probably knows airtight
either yes she does mention that she
says like well we told her there was a
dog in there many many times and so I
just assumed like she knew what she was
doing obviously she's so crazy to know
the policy and we also get so much news
about people that are getting like
dragged off the plane like you bleep
kill a duck so they're probably just
like [ __ ] I don't want to get John
out to play with my [ __ ] kids cuz I
United - yeah alright I also keep in
mind that the average person doesn't
travel more than once a year you know so
they don't know the policies they don't
know much of anything because work for
us we're viewing it from a lens of
people that travel more or jet-setters
that's true don't you know they play
like the back of your hand because
you're already nervous on the frame
she's already hitting that before like I
gotta bring the kitchen sink do I gotta
bring this everything I'm like yo just
through the kitchen when do I get my
wings do I get them before the flight if
it fits in the [ __ ] theme and you can
bring it yeah like she gets really
nervous all the stuff doesn't really
matter this human being has a very like
poor value of like life like living
things you don't need like just to even
put a dog in that
apartment alone is let you inhumane
United mean we get a picture of the
flashes remain anonymous Oh something
like a little wrong with her like I
don't think I could pick a dog and just
shove them into a [ __ ] dick you know
what I mean well I mean she's claiming
she didn't hear news I would say the
same [ __ ] though I would say the same
[ __ ] Johnny man now why are united and
like these domestic airplane American
airline yeah what American like why are
they so [ __ ] me because they hate us
like but what's the why is it like
JetBlue is cool because they don't hate
you yeah or like virgin hey did you pay
a little bit you get what you pay you
pay to for them to treat but it's not
even that much more money right no
really it's like $30 I know but have you
ever been have you ever flown Spirit
Airlines oh yeah they literally spit at
you as you get your ticket like if you
hate I did chairs but it's like a $40
difference though it's like $100 it's
really it's pretty big it's a pretty big
different thing they've charged you for
every single step of everything turns
out to be more expensive than if you
would have just gone with and they're
all weight like 95% of times are always
delayed I do yes and and they have the
people who work the ticketing booth also
work on the airplane yes so it's like if
you're not there like an hour beforehand
like because they're already working on
the airplane so you're done you're
they're [ __ ] already you're not
getting on the flight and one time I was
on a spirit of flight and I was like yo
can I get a cup of water and the lady
she threw a shoe at me hey do I shoot my
head and she's like shut the [ __ ] up
feels you feel that way the whole flight
you just feel like I'm sorry my favorite
favorite airline Southwest yeah you're
cheap your favorite airline I mean
they're cheap and they have the best
customer service flight attendants and
customer service hands down yeah how
could how come they can be cheap within
nice JetBlue virgin JetBlue I think Jeb
was here and then virgin might be like
right the agent
a good Singapore Airlines Asian airlines
the [ __ ] flight attendants get
on their knees when they talk to you
dude and Singapore Airlines all the
stewardesses are hot and if they're not
hot they get keep the [ __ ] out if they
get pregnant they get kicked off [ __ ]
that's like about Asian airlines because
then I have they don't have tenure or
Union yeah there's age limit yep dude
there's the nicest people ever yep I
sneeze in a lady's face and she's like
thank you just like try to one-up it
concert you like spit in her eyes I have
to say this though for all the domestic
flights you know who are the best or gay
flight attendants know for sure who Liz
and when they get on the intercom is the
best oh yeah like how come you could be
in a good mood how come you could
provide good service yeah but then these
old hags are [ __ ] mean as [ __ ] but
I'll do the the JetBlue or the the
Virgin Airlines like we're taking off
now video like safety video it's the
best no they got friends are in that I
love it yeah our friends are in it
friends are the dancers I can't hang
with it man
I like I'm like please stop pandering to
me please old maybe commercial yeah
that's what I'm saying
Southwest is the best
[Music]